from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between snickers in the uk and the us
this is food wars
in the us our snickers come in seven
sizes the smallest one is something
called bites which i could not get my
hands on i looked on amazon they're way
too expensive i don't know why either if
i had snickers bites they'd be in share
size bags which is about 80.2 grams and
a grab and go bites bag which is
133.2 grams the next size up from that
are these the minis
look at this little guy
next size from that is the fun size the
halloween candy size
then from there we have the 100 calorie
bar
next size up from that is of course the
standard snickers bar
next size up is the share size of the
two bars
and the biggest size
this one
the slice and share this is one pound or
roughly
453.6 grams
in the uk snickers bars come in a range
of sizes now candy bar sizes are a
controversial topic in the uk because
it's well known that they've been
shrinking in recent years due to that
there may be some slight discrepancies
between the sizes depending on where you
get your candy bars but we've tried to
be as comprehensive as possible we'll
start on this side with the smallest one
we can get which is a 20 gram 99 calorie
snickers bar from there we move up to a
snack size bar which is 35.5 grams then
we have a couple of forms of single bars
the first one being this one which comes
in a multi-pack and is 41.7 grams next
up is what we think is the standard
single bar which is this one which is 48
grams recently in the uk they've
introduced these creamy peanut butter
bars these are little bite-sized pieces
and each one is 18.25 grams these come
as a portion of three like this bar here
or as a bag of ten the largest snickers
in the uk is this one the snickers duo
now this contains two 41.7 gram bars
leaving the total at 83.4 grams
[Music]
a u.s snickers bar has the following
milk chocolate which is made up of sugar
cocoa butter chocolate skim milk lactose
milk fat soy lecithin and artificial
flavors peanuts corn syrup sugar palm
oil skim milk lactose salt egg whites
and artificial flavors
in the uk a snickers bar contains the
following
sugar peanuts glucose syrup skimmed milk
powder cocoa butter cocoa mass sunflower
oil palm fat lactose and protein from
whey from milk whey powder from milk
milk fat emulsifier soy lecithin salt
coconut oil egg white powder natural
vanilla extract milk protein milk
chocolate contains milk solids 14
minimum and milk chocolate contains
vegetable fat in addition to cocoa
butter according to uk rules a product
must contain no less than 25 cocoa
solids to be considered milk chocolate
and in the u.s the rule is our milk
chocolate must contain no less than 10
of chocolate liqueur which is a roughly
equal mix of cocoa salads and cocoa
butter also it's worth pointing out for
snickers specifically you'll notice our
version contains corn syrup whereas the
uk snickers has glucose syrup what's the
difference well corn syrup can be a type
of glucose syrup but not all glucose
syrups are made from corn liquid glucose
can be derived from lots of different
fruits and vegetables like grapes
apricots cranberries jackfruits etc
according to the usda and on name alone
i'm going to go ahead and assume that
corn syrup is only made from
corn
i realized that you're probably not
eating snickers to be healthy but
research has shown that many of the
detrimental effects associated with
added sugars are due to fructose rather
than glucose
[Music]
now people in the uk really turn their
noses up at us chocolate our chocolate
just tends to be way richer and smoother
and whenever i've had american chocolate
in the past i'm always left with like a
weird vomity aftertaste from it and i'm
not entirely sure why one potential
reason for the difference is the uk
chocolate tends to have a higher fat and
cocoa content it has been a while since
my last u.s chocolate experience i
picked some hershey's up from an
american store i'm gonna try it and see
if it's the same
this has like a weird glossiness to it
that i don't fully trust what have i got
on this
the texture's bad this is like grainy
definitely not as smooth as a uk
chocolate bar that i'm used to i'm not
getting quite so much of the vomit
aftertaste as i seem to remember which
is good i guess i'm taking uk chocolate
anyway i'm afraid so i was thinking
there's a hair in here i chew i've never
compared the two so i'm going to break
off a piece of the uk and the us
i mean just by virtue of like the
distribution of stuff it looks different
doesn't it
i don't know what uk vomit tastes like
but my vomit doesn't taste like that and
now for the first time that i'm aware of
i'm going to try a uk snickers
the chocolate is way smoother
way creamier
way more flavorful
and i don't know
how this is possible
but i g the the peanuts
are way nicer that's what i notice of
that bite and i have more peanuts or the
peanuts are more pronounced like it's
not even close man that was great
i thought it was going to be like yeah
no that is like a stark difference to
say the least that is a stark difference
and way better wow
[Music]
in the u.s a snickers bar this one
specifically has 250 calories 12 grams
of fat 4.5 grams of saturated fat 125
milligrams of sodium 32 grams of carbs
28 grams of sugar and 4 grams of protein
something to note a few years ago the
mars corporation did away with the
king-sized candy bugs to cut portion
sizes to 250 calories or below but
this share size says it has two portions
of 220 calories right please this is the
serving size i don't know how many
people are actually getting this to
share but that pales in the comparison
of hungry people who are getting exactly
this one to eat okay that is a dirty
trick it's not 220 calories it's 440
calories the share size give me a break
in the uk a 48 gram stickers bar which
comes in slightly bigger at 1.69 ounces
nice
contains the following
245 calories 13.4 grams of fat 4.6 grams
of saturated fat 88 milligrams of sodium
26.1 grams of carbs of which 21.6 a
sugar and 4.6 grams of protein the most
calorific snickers you can get in the us
is the snickers slice and share this is
a one pound snickers bar for sharing
yeah right and it's 2080 calories so i'm
gonna quiz connor the cameraman right
now on here it says 130 calories but it
says per serving how many serving sizes
do you think this is
eight you think it's eight double it
sixteen
it's six they expect
16 people to
split this
what
no
maybe maybe four
in the uk the most calorific snickers
bar is the duo bar now one of these if
you eat the whole thing will contain 426
calories
[Music]
here are all the snickers products
you'll find in the uk that you won't
find easily in the us
here's all the snickers varieties native
to the u.s you can't get really in the
uk unless they have access to the
internet
they're native to here we'll start with
this one which is actually a new product
in the uk as well it's a 99 calorie
snickers bar look at that
teeny tiny snickers bar i mean i guess
the point of these is if you're trying
to diet or lose weight but i feel like
having a small amount like this just
makes me want even more so i would
probably eat one of these and then go
back and finish off the rest of the box
which ends up being counter productive
then we're onto this one which
apparently you guys don't have in the us
as well which is the snickers duo not a
huge amount to say about this one it's
just the classic snickers bar but
obviously split into two smaller bars
then run through this one which is the
snickers crisp this is another new
product which i have not tried before so
i might dissect it to see what's going
on inside oh it's like two little bits
okay
okay
so it's like a snickers bar but instead
of the nougat base you get some rice
krispies
that's worse than the classic snickers
also how do you pronounce is it nougat
nougat versus nougat sound off in the
comments
i was surprised to learn that you guys
don't have fun size or bite size
snickers maybe a good thing so we have
the snickers two to go bar and they have
the snickers duo bar
feels like it's the same thing now they
look at it right can we confirm that
those are the same thing or that they're
different
peanut brownie
[Music]
no
not not into that at all snickers almond
also i couldn't get my hands on it but
in the u.s you can also get a snickers
almond butter and a snickers maple
almond butter i don't know where those
are but i really want those okay so i
feel like it's so sick
i'm gonna get so sick
yeah if i had my choice i'd probably get
one of these instead of a regular
snickers i was able to get hold of a
couple of the us exclusives i got hold
of the crunchy peanut butter one and the
peanut brownie one now i love any
combination of peanut and chocolate so i
want to try the crunchy peanut butter
one to see how it compares to our creamy
peanut butter one peanut and chocolate
is just a goat combination
[Music]
i actually don't love that the texture
on the peanut butter is a bit weird bit
grainy let's try the creamy version in
the uk to see if that's any better
yeah okay this one's better the texture
is better the caramel has a bit more
firmness to it so you get a contrast
between that and the peanut butter the
peanut butter itself is less grainy and
awful and also it's just like slightly
less aggressively sweet than the us
version so
i think we win this round
as i said i also got hold of the peanut
brownie snickers bar so let's give this
one a try
it's not bad i think my feedback for
this and also the crunch you want would
be to have more whole peanuts in there
because you know then you get the
texture contrast you get flavor no one's
going to complain with more filling
i mean
you have to be as curious as i am about
this
one big snickers
okay
this
proves my point what about this makes it
look like i mean it's not perforated
it's not in different sections i want to
point out this guy
comes in squares right so they possess
the technology to be able to break this
up for sharing but they're they're
expecting you to buy this
and
look it's just a giant snickers bar
and technically you're supposed to share
it but technically you can share any
candy bar if you have a knife but this
to me looks like there was no attempt
once it's out of the package to imply
that you should be sharing this
i'm gonna be so sick tonight
i'm so sick
there's a bad deal